imagine yourself standing on the Bay of
judgment the frying hot sun is beaming
down on your head
Thea is rushing through your veins
you're thinking have I done enough then
suddenly
you are called out as one of Allah's
neighbors neighbors imagine the only you
feel happiness would rush through your
veins when you realize that you are one
of the best ones to attain Paradise
here's what you must do to become a lost
neighbor on the Bay of judgment islamnet
is establishing a huge Masjid complex in
Norway they have mashallah purchased a
big property with a 2 700 square meter
building they now need our support to
reconstruct this old building into the
biggest Masjid and Community Center in
Norway inshallah the prophet salallahu
said on the day of judgment Allah will
call out where are my neighbors where
are my neighbors the
say oh Lord deserves to be your neighbor
he will reply where are the people who
maintained the mosques
you donate to establish and maintain
this Masjid you will inshallah be in the
category of those blessed people whom
Allah will call as his neighbors and you
and inshallah be sharing in these
rewards for the Salah being established
in that Masjid five times a day 365 days
a year the kids memorizing my Quran and
all of natawa and the shahadas from the
non-muslims embracing Islam and so much
more so take action right now click the
button to donate and secure your reward
inshallah and share this video for extra
Rewards